taylor's with us in pennsylvania hi
Taylor how are you hi baby how are you
better than I deserve
how can I help thank you so I have been
attacking the baby steps my mom gifted
me FPU in September so I've been really
excited about tackling baby step number
two I'm currently in graduate school
with two more years left and I was
content with taking out loans for this
next coming year and saving for the last
year but now I'm thinking that I should
say for both which gets me down a little
bit because I was really excited about
attacking my debt so I just want to get
some feedback and it's like on your
personal perspective cool so what are
you studying in your masters counseling
Child and Family Therapy and trauma
insulin therapy perfect okay so you
finish your masters and get licensed in
the state of Pennsylvania and become a
therapist yes excellent very good how
old are you I'm 25 years old
Oh fine good for you well you've
obviously got a wonderful heart for
people otherwise you wouldn't enter into
this stuff because it's a mess if you
don't that's what I'm trying to get out
of the debt so I can help people to in
that way mm-hmm so how much debt do you
have now I currently have about seven
thousand and credit cards about four
thousand on my car and by the time I
finish this up this semester you're
borrowing my but I have already borrowed
sort of this falling spring so by the
time I finish this spring I will have
about forty thousand in student loans
okay and that those loans are already
taken out you already have received the
distributions they're already applied
for I haven't receive the distributions
that it's in the works
okay well the falls over with fall yes I
got in the fall how much you to receive
in the spring about seven thousand in
the spring and seven thousand in the
summer gotcha
and when will you complete your master's
in 2022
okay and so it costs about seven
thousand dollars a semester
it costs about ten thousand for the next
two years I'm not
summer courses so the cost goes down a
little bit
and I take it from the way you said this
you're paying off debts and things
you're working I am working full-time
right now making about 42 a year gross
good for you okay perfect all right well
the first goal for getting out of debt
is take no more can you cash flow the
spring if you don't take that seven this
year not likely but that's what I was
hoping to get on a plan for as soon as
August of next year yeah you know the
first two December I bet you can make it
yeah no I bet you can make it for sure
ring Kris bang well this ring bill is
due January about 4,800 how much do you
I currently have my thousand dollars for
baby set one and that's about it and
you've got your money coming in from
work this month mm-hmm okay call the
school office and see if they have any
kind of a payment plan to them through
the spring I'd like to break the back on
the borrowing right now if we can okay
and if they let you pay part of it in
January and part of it in February or
something like that and you can figure
out a way to you know scratch the
Nichols out of the corner of the couch
and pull that off I'd like to see you do
that because I think it's going to give
you some emotional boost to do that
mm-hmm so first goal is I'm not worried
about you paying off any debt until you
graduate I don't want you to take out
another time proceeding any way you can
avoid the spring avoid the spring but
for sure from now on goal number one is
borrow no more beyond the borrow no more
once you've got the money to finish
school if you've got some extra money
above that and you want to start paying
down debts that's fine but borrow no
more you can't get out of debt while you
keep borrowing money
that's chasing your tail